i'm a filmmaker my job is to make fake
scenes look real and i can tell you from
showing you one simple photograph
that that the moon landings are shot
with electrical lighting i mean if you
go out in sunlight i can share my screen
if you want shadows always run parallel
you and a friend go out on a sunny day
and you'll see your shadows will never
intersect but in some of the moon
pictures
do you have the pictures to show us to
explain what you mean by it yeah take
the lead let's see what you have let's
let's uh
and folks if you're watching this right
now put a thumbs up if you
believe moon landing happened put a
thumbs down if you don't believe
it happened if the topic interests you
smash that subscribe button but
bart show us what you mean by this
lighting
so here is a picture that i took in
sunlight you'll see that the shadows
because the sun is about a thousand
times bigger in diameter than the earth
that it casts shadows in the same
direction over an entire continent right
here's a picture that at nasa claims was
taken on the moon
okay
here you see the shadows
are
from an object about five feet apart
from one another here's the astronaut
shadow going at 12 o'clock here's the
shadow of a rock about five feet away
it's going at nine o'clock
i mean this is one this is all the proof
that you need that the moon landings are
fake my job as a filmmaker is to make
fake scenes look real
i use electrical lighting all of the
time and when i looked at those pictures
uh
ten years after i had heard bill casey
on television for the first time when i
was a professional filmmaker i said
these things are guaranteed 100 percent
shot in electrical lighting i mean there
it is right here this is all the proof
that you need that we didn't go to the
moon and then in the course of making a
funny thing happened on the way to the
moon we found classified footage of them
faking part of the photography right in
front of your eyes i can share that now
or share that in the future uh show it
to us
you're on a roll right now let's see it
okay you just messed up with our head
today but go ahead you're on a roll
okay well here is um
here's what i when i popped in this tape
and what was on the label of the tape
and what was
uh actually on the tape
of course this is this is in a
copyrighted film from me a funny thing
happened on the way to the moon
i popped in this tape and researching my
film
and it said do not show to the public
okay mind you i had asked him
for all the footage from just the first
mission figuring if they faked it there
are more they were more likely to have
made a mistake the first time they faked
it so i pop in this tape it says do not
show to the public right and then i'm
going to cue up the next shot of it here
and then i see this particular shot here
of what is allegedly
the blue earth floating in space because
at this point in the mission they're
supposed to be 130 000 miles away from
the earth
and this is allegedly with the camera up
against their window shooting the earth
far away which it's not
they were on the rocket but they never
left earth orbit and what a surprise
here we are 50 years later and they
still cannot send an astronaut beyond
earth orbit isn't that amazing so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]